thank you for again giving me the chance
of presenting another talk so the next
talk that I'd like to present is on
Robin so Robin is an asynchronous python
web framework uh with the rust runtime
and I'll also give a quick introduction
on why did we require this and how it
will be useful uh specifically when it
comes to being able to create very quick
uh run time right so just a quick
introduction about what the story about
Robin so basically uh in early 2021
there was a huge approach within the
entire Reddit community of building with
rust and a lot of developers were using
rust as a programming language which is
actually a really great programming
language because it provides better
performance than C plus plus but having
the less security issues that you
usually find with things such as uh
pointers in C plus plus so it's actually
better and today rust is you being is
actually being used for a lot of
different use cases so uh during this
period rust was being used to rewrite a
lot of the common applications with the
help of rust and during that time
sanskar who is the original uh
maintainer and the original creator of
this particular project he decided to
basically create
um a kind of a for one of his projects
he's decided to use uh flask but flask
does not support asynchronous methods
right out of the box so that's why he
decided why not just create
anything flask and of course there was
fast API but he wanted to use
um rust and to go with this entire theme
of building with rust and that's how
Robin was born now one of the biggest
benefit that we get with the help of uh
Robin as compared to other python
Frameworks now
um if you might be aware with python uh
there's a global globally known
notorious uh Global interpreter lock in
Python that doesn't allow for
concurrency and uh this is more related
to multi-threading locking and python
does not allow for uh true concurrency
to actually take place whereas uh rust
does allow that and rust uses native
threading for much faster execution and
uh that is why robin since it uses uh
the rust as its main framework for
managing your entire multi-threading
that's why it all also comes with a
coupled server and that allows you to
have basically an asynchronous server
Gateway interface right out of that and
again if you want to check out more
details about uh the asci server you can
check out this particular issue and if
we also compare amongst uh the different
uh python Frameworks and Robin you can
see that uh here is a performance
Benchmark that has been done for uh 10
000 requests for standard HTTP get
requests and uh keep a note that one uh
there has been one process and one
worker used for the rest request and you
can see that Robin is actually the
fastest even in comparison to Django
fast API and flask which are some of the
most common uh python Frameworks that
are existing today and if you want to go
a bit more deeper into understanding how
does uh
how does uh basically
um
how does Robin actually work and this is
basically the performance Benchmark
um how does uh Robin actually work so uh
basically uh the big rectangle that you
can see is the rust runtime and this is
uh where we first take our python code
and it gets converted into a rust code
and uh all the requests that you see are
basically sent into this work worker
event cycle and uh these requests are
basically then sent to a router and the
router has essentially the python code
object for every corresponding route
that it wants to execute and then it
will basically go ahead and push the
objects into this thread pool which is
our event pool where it will distribute
it across the multiple threads depending
upon the total number of CPU resources
that you have and this way it is able to
very easily manage uh the
multi-threading aspect which is commonly
lacking in the python Frameworks that
are written in Native Python and of
course in case you want to go ahead and
actually build much larger applications
in case you might have let's say
multiple workers you could distribute
them across CPU cores and then just
imagine having multiple instances of
these process they could be scaled
across very easily across multiple cores
so the main idea behind Robin and using
rust is that your entire main logic is
converted into rust objects and then
then internal thread pool that is used
within that trust runtime is responsible
for uh taking care of all the different
requests that you have and because of
the easy memory management and the
thread Pool Management lifecycle
management with the help within this
runtime you're able to get very quick
and efficient a processing of your
threads and that of course uses the
multi-threading aspect that comes
inbuilt with rust and this is a simple
uh usage of how you can basically get
started so you just have to do pip
install Robin and of course is a simple
example it has been built with this very
similar uh like you know of example or
developer experience that you usually
find uh with flask so you define a robin
and then you define your either your get
methods or your post methods and then
you start your app by defining the port
and uh in order to quickly also
demonstrate I will go ahead and share my
screen so let me go ahead and do that uh
I'll just quickly share my screen now
and stop sharing and share my entire
screen uh let me go ahead and do that
now over here I am sharing my Postman um
sorry my vs code and here I have
basically two different examples the
first example that I have is of course
the one that I showcased uh here we are
just having a hello world application
I've imported Robin again you just have
to do pip install Robin and I'll quickly
go ahead and run my app so for this I'll
do python3 app.py and it starts running
at localhost 5000 so I'll do this go and
take a look at my local news 5000 and
over here you can see it's a simple
Hello World app now the other
application that I'm showing is a
graphql application where we are using a
strawberry uh that provides native
graphql support with uh with python and
here is an example where I'm using a
graphql based API again I've defined
specific methods uh for either fetching
or also of course creating new posts
with the help of graphql and using the
them alongside this back-end framework
this is Robin so in order to go ahead
and do that I'll just Define this as uh
Python 3 graphql app Dot py and I'll
start running this if I just refresh
this will load a graphql editor and then
of course I can create my requests and
send them uh which will be managed with
the help of Robin
so uh that is a quick understanding of
what exactly is Robin and how you can
get started so of course if you want to
get involved uh you can check out the
GitHub repository which is github.com
and you can take a look at the
repository over here it's a fairly uh
active open source project and it has
already within a space of just a few
months it has already gotten more than
uh close to 2000 stars and of course you
can also follow the project on Twitter
and um in case you want to get started
with the community there is also a
Discord community that you can join in
order to get started and uh within the
docs you'll also find certain uh getting
started code so if you want to explore
uh Robin a bit more you can find some
starter examples uh that have been
provided including how to create a
simple HTTP Services HTML files or even
interact with with the help of a
database so you can check out this
framework and actually compare it
yourself with a similar other
applications with a flight with like you
know a flask and with um
Django as well so that what makes uh the
robin framework so special is that it
has async support and of course since it
uses the rust runtime it's very fast and
manages multi-threading very easily so
uh that's a quick uh overview of the
entire uh project and I'll stop
presenting and I'm open to questions now
thanks so much
uh all right uh perfect uh thank shave I
think we still have around one minute
left
um
yeah I think uh it's it's it's a
interesting how uh you know where we're
seeing so much of rewriting different
parts of python in non-python
so you know like whether it's the pi
scripts or you know even just you know
before that right like all the all the
uh
uh you know pie pie stuff like that um
one interesting thing that I'm very
excited about is uh webassembly and
python so uh recently we saw a number of
different applications where you could
actually run Django on the browser with
the help of webassembly so rust
webassembly in Python like they have a
very good combination especially because
of the fact that machine learning is
typically Associated so much heavily
with python and if you want to run them
on edge devices you can use like you
know things like webassembly to be able
to manage those so yeah uh definitely
very excited about the prospect of web
assembly as well and how it interrupts
with python